welcome back to CBS mornings here at 7
30. we're talking about a recent study
raising concerns about the safety of
popular gel manicures researchers at the
University of California in San Diego
found that the UV nail dryers used a
hardened gel nail polish cure is the
term for it may increase the risk of
skin cancer our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner is looking
into this for us and a good morning
good morning you know Tony there are a
lot of people who love their gel nails
but this study may get them thinking
about changing their practices like the
woman we spoke to a former Miss Illinois
who competed in the Miss USA pageant
before Carolina Jasco won the Miss
Illinois contest in 2018 getting gel
manicures had been part of her beauty
routine all through high school so I
would get my nails done pretty
frequently a gel manicure uses special
compounds to create a harder
long-lasting nail cover it requires the
use of a dryer that uses Ultraviolet
light to harden or cure the gel nails
just having like that regular like nail
polish isn't going to be enough it might
not last as long as you want it might
not look as nice as he wants it was
during one of her frequent manicures
that the salons technician noticed a
dark line under her thumbnail I remember
my nail tech looking at me and he was
like oh what happened it's like oh is it
a bruise like did you hit yourself or
slam your hand and I was like maybe like
I must have you know I didn't even think
about it but a week later she was in
pain and her nail looked infected and
when she saw the doctor you have to have
a biopsy right away because it doesn't
look good Jasco says on her 18th
birthday she received her biopsy results
melon Noma the most serious kind of skin
cancer which if it spreads can be deadly
a rare form known as acryl melanoma I
just remember like
feeling like numb like I honestly didn't
really feel anything Jasco underwent
multiple surgeries doctors removed her
thumbnail and grafted skin from her
groin to replace the missing skin on her
thumb the cause impossible to say for
sure but Jasco says her doctors
suspected genetics because her mother
had had melanoma but also her use of
those UV nail dryers for me it was very
confusing at that time where I was like
oh my gosh I've been so careful you know
I've never been in a tanning bed like I
always wear sunscreen and I felt so
young and it was confusing her case made
headlines and prompted researchers at
the University of California San Diego
to study the potential hazards of those
UV dryers researcher Maria zavagi that
kind of was one of our motivation or
inspiration because there was a
potential link between these machines
and cancer what they call a first of its
kind study found those UV dryers do in
fact damage cells and cause mutations
typically seen in skin cancer in the
laboratory cells they analyzed after one
20-minute session of exposure to the UV
dryers it resulted in 20 to 30 percent
of cells dying while three consecutive
20-minute sessions of exposure resulted
in 65 to 70 percent of cells dying when
we see cell death it means that there
has been a huge amount of damage to the
cell that led it to Die the Food and
Drug Administration told us it's
reviewing the study's findings but its
current advice is that it views nail
curing lamps as low risk when used as
directed the trade Association for the
UV and Electron Beam industry radtek
said last week that all scientific
evidence demonstrates that UV nail lamps
are safe when used according to
well-established safe practices but the
results of the study made zivagi stop
her own gel manicures I did not want to
expose myself to more cancer risk
factors Cleveland Clinic dermatologist
Melissa pillion if you had your way
would you have patients not use these at
all I think it's best to not use these
at all because we know that they can
cause cancer what we don't know yet is
how much how many times you have to use
it how frequently you have to use it to
increase your risk some of that we won't
know until people have been using these
machines for 20 or 30 years at which
point it will be too late jasco's cancer
was fully removed but she has since
advocated for skin cancer awareness and
knows she's lucky hers was caught early
so it's like right now I don't have my
thumbnail but I could have lost my thumb
I could have lost my hand it could have
been so much worse one thing she didn't
know that she was the inspiration behind
the study it does make me emotional
because I can't believe that my story
would like make that much of an impact
on someone or be like that important so
it's really cool it really is making you
more yeah I know I'm like I didn't even
expect that but yeah it's really cool it
makes me feel like wow like this was
important and this is important
well Dr pillion says if you do want to
get gel manicures try to make them just
for special occasions and not too often
she also says you can wear UV protective
gloves and sunscreen and signs to look
for of skin cancer include discolored
spots like black blue red or brown and
also bruises under the nail David
Anna thank you when the researcher doing
the study stops getting gel nails yes
that's pretty interesting Yeah Anna
Werner with a public service here thank
you thank Carolina for sharing her story
because a lot of women use get those
jail manicures yeah yeah